all right guys
bang bang i've got kevin o'leary mr
wonderful here thank you so much for
doing this sir
i love doing this great to be on thank
you so much
absolutely let's jump right in for like
the like three people who are watching
who don't know who you are
uh give us kind of the two minute on
your background and we'll get into some
of the different investment asset
classes that uh that we're gonna discuss
today
well i'm an entrepreneur i mean you know
the good bad and the ugly is every
entrepreneur's had some great successes
and catastrophic failures
i'm no different i got involved in shark
tank 12 years ago that's been an
incredible platform everybody knows the
show now all around the world
and we've launched so many businesses
created you know millions of dollars of
of wealth for people and sold billions
of dollars with the product so we're
very we're very excited about that
but basically it's the celebration of
entrepreneurship and i'm an investor i
invest in a lot of different things uh
some really work out
some don't and i you know i take my
lumps like everybody else
i had an opportunity i was when i was
young my dad worked the united nations
so i've lived
in cambodia tunisia ethiopia cyprus
france japan switzerland
germany everywhere every two years
different place
so like an army kid but that gave me a
different perspective in terms of how i
think about investing globally now
because i've been to all those places
and i think you know
i think as an investor a little
differently with that perspective
yeah one of the things i want to talk
about is obviously the kind of macro
environment
and uh the economic chaos that's
occurred because of the coronavirus
you've been pretty outspoken about the
ppp loans
and a lot of just the state of personal
finance of people in canada and the
united states
how are you thinking about that today
and kind of where do you think we go
from here
well i lived through the whole ppp loan
um
it started in in march and i i have i
have
i have crystal clear clarity on what
happened you know nine months later
basically
and so here's my observations about it
um it was a very blunt instrument
it was necessary in some ways but i
would guesstimate now that about a third
of it was completely wasted
because it went to businesses that
aren't going to survive regardless of
how much you stimulate them
and and the reason that is occurring is
that because of a pandemic that nobody
could have anticipated
consumer preferences and purchase
behaviors have dramatically changed and
i'll give you an example movie theaters
you would have never thought that that
you know all of these very strategically
located movie theaters in malls all over
america
would ever go to zero but they are going
to go to zero for a bunch of reasons
number one
you know we've gone from 1800 malls to
1200 miles down to a thousand miles
we're on our way to probably 500 miles
that is not a preference on how
consumers purchase anymore they've gone
online they've also started to consume
all their digital content on a streaming
basis either to their 80
inch monitor in their basement or to
their personal device
who cares which one it is the point is
that that's not a business i as the
taxpayer
would have wanted to fund because i
think it's going to zero anyways
the wedding industry same thing dramatic
changes going on and all of the billions
of dollars
spent on weddings there hasn't been a
wedding with 200 people in it since
march
7th why do i know that because i have
lots of investments in the wedding
industry
most of them are going to go to zero on
the other hand 80
of my companies have done the great
digital pivot have moved the focus of
their
sales out of retail direct to consumer
and i would
remind everybody when you sell direct to
consumer you're making 100 cents on the
dollar not
50 cents as you do in retail so as a
result they've been able to come back
stronger than ever with a bigger focus
on telling their stories
and building relationships with their
own customers that all happened
in eight months look at nike's numbers
last quarter they reported two weeks
ago they're now one-third of every sale
they make around the world is direct to
consumer
they don't need retail as much as they
used to that's all happening
and i'm very very bullish even though 20
of my companies aren't going to make it
the other 80 are going to come out of
this mess a lot stronger than they went
in
and they're going to develop new
business models and i call it the great
digital pivot
america 2.0 so i'm optimistic
yeah and we just saw black friday
numbers that have started to surface as
we're recording this
and one of the things that was really
interesting is that over
seven billion dollars of the
transactions are coming from
uh online and so is that something where
that was just the virus
accelerating those online trends or do
you think that we actually would have
seen something similar even without the
virus
and it's just a shift of preference
now i have pretty good data on this what
the virus has done has accelerated 36
months
of online sales in other words if you
were budgeting for three years from now
to be 50 online direct to consumer
it was going to take you 36 months three
years and that was your capital
expenditure plan as well as for many of
my companies we achieved that
in five months and so we by necessity we
had to close retail and we just reached
out
using geo locked as on facebook using
insta using all the different social
media platforms
and we learned that our customers were
willing to at least two-thirds of the
time
buy direct from us and they're never
going to go back to retail buy the
product or service and so
it's been a dramatic acceleration and in
some ways you would have never taken
that risk you would have never shut
down your headquarters you would have
never said i'm never going to go visit a
buyer at a big box retailer
and yet we couldn't so we started using
zoom and other video technologies
we're doing meetings direct for q1 on
zoom i'm meeting
with my ceos next week on a series of
calls direct to buyers
for q1 product placements that normally
would have cost us ten thousand dollars
with the business travel
we're spending zero on aircraft we're
doing it directly in 18 minutes
on zoom calls far more efficient and by
the way when the pandemic's
over we're not changing that either i'm
cutting my business travel and
entertainment by
50 in my portfolio over the next 24
months we are saving
a fortune yeah uh one of the things that
happened with ppp was you also got to
see kind of
uphand uh up close uh the financial
state of many of the employees of these
businesses and i know that you've talked
in the past about
just your shock as to how bad they are
at saving and kind of their financial
investments you've created some
technology to try to help them
talk a little bit about what you saw
when you started to understand what the
employees of these businesses were doing
yeah this totally freaked me out i mean
i didn't see this coming i could have
never guessed it
i mean there's so many cases like that
this pandemic so here's how it went down
starting in the third week of march as
soon as we got to read the ppp plan it
was passed on to four o'clock on a
friday
in the house and we all got it to our
accountants and lawyers and i spent the
weekend reading it
what it said was you had to take a
snapshot of your payroll on
feb 15 and then it would be compared
against your payroll june
30 and that would determine the
structure of the loan you're about to
get or how much you get in the first
place
but you had to have good accounting
records and you had to have
really good records around payroll so
you know that was the first lesson i
learned some of my companies were kind
of sloppy in their accounting
and that really hurt them because we
couldn't get the ppp for them because
they didn't have the records but the
ones that did
the there was a huge panic going on
amongst all the employees not just in my
companies
but the up and down channels of supply
chains tens of thousands of people
in their late 20s early 30s freaking out
and i didn't know why until i figured it
out 95 percent of them had no more than
two weeks of salary and cash in the bank
that's it they had no plan for savings
they had no investment strategy they had
nothing and they're they're now sort of
three or four years into their career
they haven't put anything aside
that's crazy that's a failure in
financial literacy so what i did was
i formed an app with a team and i built
a business called
bean stocks b-e-n-b-e-a-n-s-t-o-x
and what it does and i realize this by
talking to these employees nobody knows
how to buy a stock
i mean there's this whole you know
thinking that everybody knows how to
trade
and buy stocks and develop portfolios
are diversified
very few people can do that so with bean
stocks we made it
completely simple investing you just put
100 bucks if you can aside a week
it puts it to a diverse portfolio of
exchange traded funds
across a wide range of sectors and
stocks and it lets you over time
build a portfolio and the reason i did
that in telling them this is
if you can afford to put a hundred bucks
aside a week
and the markets do over the next 40
years what they've done over the last
150 is give you
six to eight percent a year of
compounded returns i'm not talking about
saving i'm talking about investing now
you can't get that in the savings
account you got to put it into the
market you'll retire with about a
million and a half dollars in the bank
that's a good nest egg to have because
you don't know what the next 40 years
are going to do to you but you do want
certainty
that you can somehow save a hundred
bucks a week that's what being stocks is
all about
anybody can download it check it out i
work very hard on it
and what i would say about it and people
say what's what's the difference between
that app and all the other apps out
there
this app invests according to my
investment philosophy
i'm very conservative i couldn't find
anything that was a conservative that i
was
towards long-term investing so i built
it myself
yeah this is really interesting because
one of the things people give me a lot
of flack for is i always say that anyone
can become a millionaire you just have
to have discipline and have a really
really long time horizon obviously you
got to be young to be able to do it
but this idea of saving a little bit but
investing it not just putting it in a
savings account how do you think about
or talk to some of these employees about
how much they should save and kind of
keep in that rainy day fund versus what
they should be investing into the
markets in a kind of conservative way
well you're dead right you've asked the
right question there's a big difference
between
saving and investing saving you don't
even beat the inflation rate
anymore basically that's the amount of
cash you should have on hand
just in case poopoo hits the fan
catastrophic illness in your family
car accidents something tragic occurs i
like to have
90 days of window so whatever it costs
you to live for a month
have three of those just in case poopoo
hits the fan so 90 days
but then you should find a way to change
your
expending habits and you know the people
spend money on all kinds of crap they
don't need
you look at your closet full of clothes
you never wear anymore
shoes you don't wear anymore and all the
junk you don't need in consumer
electronics
take a little bit of that and just
invest it not save it
invest it and that is where you take and
use an app like beanstalks
to pull 100 bucks out of your account
and automatically put it into a wide
diverse portfolio
that you hope will achieve six to eight
percent a year over a long period of
time
that's how you become a millionaire when
you're in your 60s and you have a nest
egg
that you can fall against when you want
to retire as opposed to having nothing
in the back i think the scariest outcome
for people
would be to have nothing saved in their
60s that's insane
beanstalks can help you avoid that
tragedy and that's why i did it
yeah one of the other things that's
really interesting is there's this kind
of common belief that the only way to
get more money is to save money right
what i mean by that is cut out
uh excess spending etc but one of the
things i've seen you talk about
is everyone should have a side hustle
especially if you're young and so this
idea that
it may actually be easier to go make an
extra thousand dollars than it is to cut
300
a week out of kind of your expenses why
do you think that side hustle is so
important for young people
side hustle is really a great idea and
let me explain why i used to run around
just a year ago
when i have a talk like the one we're
having right now and people say well how
should i invest
for college and i always say well
there's only three options if you want
to get a job
engineering engineering and engineering
and if you want a backup plan become an
engineer
but i don't feel that way anymore
because what i've learned in the last
nine months is when i look at the money
i've spent
on artists who are they copywriters
i've spent money on videographers video
editors
photographers animators why because i've
had to redo my entire
digital platform on all my companies so
that people would engage in the product
or service
and make it rich enough content that
they would buy direct from us as opposed
to go to retail which doesn't exist
anymore in the same way and that's all
art that's all
great storytelling that's all great
photographers now
that's a great side hustle if you know
how to cut video if you know how to use
adobe if you know how to record stuff
if you can write copy if you can do
animation if you're a good photographer
come on are you kidding the world is
screaming for those talents
and you can make plenty of money on the
side i'm paying tons of dough
to editors in israel and france and
england and australia
time shifted even in china and india all
these people that are working with us on
digital content
just so we can be working 24 7
digitizing all of our platforms
so there's a big opportunity and a lot
of kids know how to do this because
they've come here to social media they
know how to use their
cameras and a lot of the stuff that we
actually post now is shot
you know with iphone 11s and now the 12
is 4k
60 frames a second it's spectacular
video quality
that's broadcast quality we're going to
be using it for all of our social media
so i'm looking for
talented people that know how to do that
yeah that's great
because of the coronavirus and kind of
all the economic chaos
uh people have been now looking for
alternative assets and
um you probably more than most were
already positioned to do well there
i want to talk about wine and i want to
talk about watches two areas that you've
been investing heavily in
what's kind of the investment thesis for
those two assets and how's it been going
so far
well you know when you're an investor i
mean the core for me
is i like to have an investment
philosophy
you know in my case and i say this to
people it's not about
just investing for growth it's it's
investing to protect your money
in case there's a catastrophic change in
the market so
preservation of capital is my number one
mandate and towards that
one of my early investments was to found
my own um
indexing company a company that makes
exchange-traded funds and i did that i
own 50 of oh shares which is a company
that's been very successful
producing you know products like ousa a
core
subset of the s p that i can invest in
long term
so that i'm getting dividends and then
for the digital economy i told the ceo i
said
why is it that i'm spending so much
money this was two years ago
look at how much i'm spending on zoom
how much i'm spending on crowdstrike how
much i'm spending on shopify
look at my budget on jd.com on alibaba
on facebook
on docusign i'm spending millions on
these guys why don't you index
that for me figure out the top 70
companies around the world
that are digitizing the economy build me
an index and i'll invest in that
and that's what ogig was that thing is
up over 80 percent this year and i
obviously that's a big investment of
mine and the thinking for me was if i am
writing checks to those companies
why don't i own them why like why don't
i own them
because they are they are the new
they're allowing the digitization of the
global economy
they're the internet giants and they're
growing at 20 30 40
a year i mean shopify has a million
businesses on this platform now
including
all of mine and the reason i do that is
i yeah i do business with amazon that's
40
of my sales but i also want to sell
direct where i collect my own customer
data
and i can't do that with amazon so i do
with shopify that's part of the index of
ogig so that's
you know one of the ways i invest and
and i i just look at it and say to
myself
invest in things you understand how
they're growing and that's what i do
another area that really i found
interesting
and this falls into some of the
discussions we're going to have about
alternative asset classes like bitcoin
etc in a minute but
two or three years ago people kept
calling up saying kevin why
aren't you you're a known investor why
are you not investing in cannabis
why don't you have a big portfolio of
weed companies
and every time i want to invest in them
and i did my guys in washington would
tell me hey
kevin this is a schedule one narcotic
it breaches the ricoh statue if it goes
from one state to another where it's
illegal
and you're going to be a shareholder
it's a very bad outcome for you
you can't invest in cannabis for
recreational purposes
so then i got approached about a year
and a half ago to invest
in psychedelics as medicine again lsd is
a schedule one narcotic
at that time psilocybin it was an
illegal drug
i said guys how can i invest in that
it's the same thing as cannabis
and this time they said no no no these
are going to be fda approved trials
we're only doing medicine no
recreational drugs
so i became a big spokesperson for that
sector and i invested heavily in it
and one of the and the way i look at it
investing in these platforms is
invest in the ones that have a lot of
trials and a lot of different molecules
because you don't know the outcome you
don't know if the psilocybin is going to
work the llc is going to work the a18mc
is going to work
invest in something that has a big
portfolio of there are multiple trials
going on all around the world
and that one was called mind med so i
became an investor in mind mid
early on it went public it's one of my
most successful investments this year
i'm a huge advocate for it i want them
to do more trials
and just keep growing this platform
because the anecdotal evidence of micro
dosing
is really interesting to solve for
opioid addiction for everything like
depression alcoholism add
we haven't had new medicines in that
space in 37 years
this may be them that's why i'm an
investor
yeah when it comes to psychedelics
what's really interesting to me is there
is this
kind of comparison or correlation to the
cannabis industry
but you seem pretty convinced that by
only going after medical use cases and
not recreation that you can avoid a lot
of those problems
is this something where kind of once we
get the legalization like we saw in
oregon or in other places that are
working on it there's this kind of gold
rush
and just the institutional capital flows
into this space or is this something
that's going to take much
longer and it's not going to be just one
or two kind of legalizations you're
going to need kind of federal
legalization uh to really kind of get
institutional capital uh
attention and you really know what
you're talking about kiddo
you're absolutely right the reason
cannabis failed and the companies lost
80
of their values they never got any
follow-up with institutional capital
that's not going to be the problem with
psychedelics because they're not even
attempting to go into the recreational
market
they don't want to get involved in that
side of the mess they're just staying
focused on the medicinal outcomes trial
fda approval and release as a medicine
a prescribed medicine and that's how
they're getting institutional capital
including guys like me
to say i'm interested because i met the
board i met the ceo and i said listen
you tell me right now what matters more
to me is to shake your hand and tell me
you're not going to pursue
recreational drugs i have no interest in
getting involved in that
i know what that did to the cannabis
people i have nothing
no interest in that but if you're
telling me to develop medicines i can
become a big advocate and like a big
investor which i did
and so you're absolutely correct the
entire sector
of psychedelics medicine is going to
avoid that
that blow up they had in cannabis
because they're never going to pursue
recreational drugs the same way the
cannabis people did you know there's
there's groups like mothers against
drunk driving
that don't agree as using cannabis as a
recreational drug whether you feel or i
feel
that it's okay there's not enough tests
to determine
how the the the amount of thc is
affecting your driving skills
they have some saliva tests in europe
but they haven't really adopted those
here in texas or in florida
new york or california and the mothers
against drunk driving is a powerful
lobby group
and they certainly i've spoken to them
and they've talked to many senators and
governors about this stuff
and they have made their opinion known
that they they endorse
medicines they don't endorse
recreational drugs that kind of
of issue is boiling over in america but
you just saw the election the day of the
election
that washington dc and oregon approved
the legalization of psilocybin
to pursue a medicine for it and that
kicks in in about 20 months
and as a result if you look at the price
and the valuations of the companies like
my med
that are researching this their
valuations increased dramatically the
week after that decision was
made yeah and do you think that it's
going to be important for those
companies kind of long-term success to
continue to get legalization like i know
one of the things that
most investors including yourself aren't
huge fans of is basically waiting around
for politicians or regulations to change
it feels like with this though because
of the focus on the medicine and not the
recreation
that's not as big of a risk to these
businesses
you know i i make the assumption in my
investment in mind man that
they're never going to make it legal as
a recreational drug
ever and that will never come off the
schedule list it will only be allowed as
a medicine
and i think that's the best way to think
about cannabis too you can keep talking
about the individual states that are
making it legal
but until it is off the schedule on
narcotic list it is subject to rico
statues
it is a controlled substance it cannot
cross state lines
there's all kinds of problems with it
and so
i just don't see the bike administration
or certainly the trump didn't endorse it
so i think
cannabis is going to sit there forever
waiting to be legalized federally i
don't think it's going to happen
and i don't think it's going to happen
for lsd or psilocybin either
but pursuing them as medicines to
provide for the misery of opioid
addiction or alcoholism or depression or
add
or all of these syndromes that we've had
no medicine work for
i think there's a lot of interest in
determining it through clinical trials
stage one stage two stage three and in
my mid we have multiple trials
many of them in stage two that's really
important so i'm hedging my bets
you know i always ask when i'm offered
another opportunity in in uh
in a psilocybin company or a you know
psychedelic or medicine company
how many molecules how many trials
that's how i'm thinking just like an etf
do i have diversity and if i don't have
diversity
not that interested i like a lot of
different opportunities to get a
positive outcome
speaking of diversity one place where
you have an unlimited number of
of assets is in wine and watches uh what
have you been doing there and kind of
how has that gone so far
well wine is a really interesting you
know hobby and there's an old joke about
how how do you become a millionaire in
the wine business
start as a billionaire and get into wine
the truth about the wine industry is for
decades and decades and over a hundred
years
it has been called through controlled
through a byzantine distribution system
west in the mississippi three tiers of
distribution east of the mississippi two
tiers
so you have to pay two sets of
distributors it's
really really hard to make money in the
wine business the break even
is a hundred thousand cases and very
few people can do that now four
maybe five years ago now now that i
think about it the laws changed and it
allowed
makers of wine in california and
washington state
to ship direct to customers in 42 states
now when that happened the first thing i
said was wait a sec
i'm a well-known guy that loves wine
people know who i am people trust me in
selecting wine for them
why don't i partner up with somebody
like a qvc which sells
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
food in just minutes
you know they have 6.2 million viewers
there why don't i go into partnership
with them we go to the wine business
together
i'll launch the very fine wines on qvc
and see if i can get to that critical
mass of 100
000 cases well that happened in the
first weekend
and so we learned a lot about the
business we figured out the logistics of
being able to do it
and yes i was selling wine in retail
making
no money doing that now i'm in a
profitable partnership with qvc
we had a huge wine sale just before the
holiday
um you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars a minute
in wine and we continue to grow that
business because
i basically say to people look i've got
your back on wine and here's the facts
about the wine industry
97 percent of wines sold in america is
sold for under 15
a bottle so you have to figure out how
to make a great wine for under 15 and i
know how to do that
and so people that get my wine like it
they trust me to bring a pinot a
cabernet sauvignon
a chardonnay you know moscato these are
some of the varietals i've done
i've done malbecs i've done all kinds of
wines that i make and i blend
myself i think people trust my palate my
white work my wife works on the whites
she's got an amazing new world palette
she's almost a sommelier now
and so we together blend these for our
family and you know i've
extended my family through my qvcc
relationship
it's a business like all of my other
businesses it relies heavily
on social media digital direct to
consumer that is america
2.0 absolutely and watches
okay watches is a disease that's a big
problem
um nobody needs a watch anymore because
you get perfect time on your
your device and so you know i'm wearing
um an eddie mark pk um
1159 a new brand that they brought out
to two years ago this is
one of a hundred made um
you know it's very very expansive but it
actually has appreciated in value
my rolex is my patek philippe it's my
aps
um seiko grand seiko is probably the
the biggest value in the watch industry
today some of the
mechanics coming out of japan now rival
that of patek philippe i have a huge
selection of those as well
i'm buying watches as an investment
that's what i say to myself
my wife just calls me an idiot she says
how many can you possibly own
how many can you possibly use and she's
right
i have to wear three different watches a
day just to get through
just one collection i've got so it's a
big problem but i will say
today you can mark to market the value
of your watches
every 24 hours with apps like chrono 24
and my collection of watches is up 113
year over year so that's how i justify
it to myself
that i have these it's an alternative
asset class just like art
but you know i just bought another watch
yesterday that i
don't even know when i can wear it but
it's incredibly rare
and very very unique and i'm going to
wear it on
shark tank next year what's the most
expensive watch you've ever bought
that's a great question um
well i've learned i've been ripped off
now twice both
out of two different facilities so i no
longer say how many watches i own or
where they are
that's my first rule because i have a
big ensure complex insurance program now
i have them in three different cities
i'm not even saying that for north
america anymore
but i would argue that the better way to
answer that question is what's the most
valuable watch i have now
it's probably an fp jorn
one of ten made for the new york
boutique only ten ever made
um i was not an fp jordan collector when
i met this watch i
just by a happy chance was in
new york this is an interesting story
you may find interesting
i got a phone call from a friend of mine
who is
part of the royal family of the uae
united arab emirates
and maybe the largest watch collector in
the world i won't mention
his name probably is and he said to me
kevin have you ever heard of
fpjorn i said no and
this guy knows every microbrand he know
he knows every watch on earth
he is the guy in watches he said if
you're in new york why don't you just
call up the boutique they know who you
are and ask to go see some watches
so i called up fp jordan and there was a
woman there named michelle at the time
she was the manager of the
she said kevin just by happy chance and
maybe it's destiny we're having our
annual event where all of our collectors
from around the world are meeting here
in new york tonight for a giant dinner
and fp jordan himself is going to be
there and everybody in management from
switzerland
be our guest so i go zooming down to
this event
they lend me a watch to wear because i
don't own an fp jordan and i met the
craziest people i've ever met in my life
brain surgeons army generals
collectors psychologists politicians
with this crazy disease of fps joint
collecting and
journey only makes 900 watches a year
like just to get one's impossible
and that's when i saw this this uh one
of ten made for the boutique for
celebrating this big event
and i got down on my knees and begged to
buy it it was a crazy price and they
said no
i mean you've got a thousand collectors
ahead of you that have been with the
brand for years
why would you get it and i said okay
what's it gonna take
he said well maybe if you owned another
one i said i'll buy four
i'll buy four at once has anybody ever
done that
i don't think they had i did and i
became part of that family
the ftp jordan watches now for those who
collect watches if you go online and
read what's going on
prices are going from you know 50
000 to 700 000 in auction it's
crazy the fp jord himself is like
picasso but he's alive he's still alive
he makes these incredibly complex
timepieces and he's still around
so you're buying something made by him
designed by him and
a bunch of people that he works with in
switzerland i visited the factory i know
i'm going on too long you can see i'm
passionate about it but if you're into
watches you gotta check out fb
journey it's just crazy i love that
story that that's an
awesome story and i love that you bought
four instead of two
it was the only way to get the one to
ten it was the only way to get it i mean
it was just
and and and people have called me saying
will you sell that watch never
what's it worth priceless they'll never
make an eleventh
i've got one of the ten and it's just a
it's a piece of art
you know you gotta be careful because
people get bored when you talk this way
but for me
i'm infected it's a disease i love it i
love time pieces people know that
and i have a very very very eclectic
collection each year
i select eight dials to put it on shark
tank every single one has a red band
you can see this is red this was on
shark tank last year
this is an incredible time pissed this
ap
it's probably gone up in value who knows
how much and they only made
100 of them i got maybe the sixth first
one for six all right let's talk about
bitcoin you uh
early on i don't know 2012 2013 seemed
to be a proponent
then you kind of soured on it where are
you now are we a proponent
not an opponent how do you think about
it i i i do own a small amount of
bitcoin and the reason i did it was i
was teaching i'm a guest lecturer at
harvard and like
notre dame temple waterloo mcgill i
teach graduating cohorts of engineers
and at my last harvard meeting um
regarding this sector
that the class challenged me to
buy not just bitcoin but just get
involved in cryptocurrency
because their argument was look if
you're i have a five percent weighting
in gold
each quarter i have bullion which i
store and i pay to store it and i also
use
etfs to balance each quarter to up or
down to five percent
and it's been a good stabilizer against
uh you know inflation and it's you've
seen gold set a big move lately
being concerned about inflation so it
was bitcoin but bitcoin was originally
sold to me as a counterbalance to the
equity market in other words it would
move in a different direction
so if you had a big correction in the
stock market
so theoretically bitcoin would go the
other way
and it would protect your assets that's
not true
it has a very heavy correlation to the
stock market it too
achieves new highs when the market
achieves new highs and when the market's
correct
it too corrects so it's very volatile
you saw it dipped 3000 bucks last week
it's back up
over 18 today it's moving all around the
place so
i would argue it's fair enough i have a
couple of questions for you to answer
and everybody that's listening
why is it that only one cryptocurrency
gets this designation bitcoin because if
you bought a basket of cryptocurrencies
two years ago and there's many many many
of them
you haven't made a lot of money there's
simply nothing like bitcoin and so it's
the only one
and that's a little perverse in the
sense if you look at the stock market
it's not the stock market it's a market
of stocks
there's many different ones you can buy
but you can't seem to play that game
in the crypto space you have to be very
concentrated to get these returns
in one cryptocurrency bitcoin that
bothers me a little bit
okay on the other hand wait let's talk
about that for one second
so if you think of an economy right take
the u.s economy for example
there's only one currency right the u.s
dollar
if you think of euro right there's one
currency that is the nation-state
currency or kind of the selected
currency right and if you kind of go to
the global
economy right there's really the global
reserve currency which is the dollar and
kind of each micro
economy has their own currency if you
think of uh kind of the digital economy
or you talked a lot about digitizing the
world
the digital economy doesn't have a
native currency right so if you were
talking to somebody like a jack dorsey
and ask him why is he so bullish on
bitcoin what he would actually say is
the first native currency of the
internet or the digital world
is bitcoin now the same thing applies
though that you're not going to have
10 currencies right you're only going to
have one currency that is native to that
environment and so
it becomes this really interesting thing
where if you think of it as an economy
right bitcoin does become that global
reserve currency of the digital economy
right i totally agree but that is not
what has not happened yet here's the
problem
let's say i want to i want to use
bitcoin as a currency to make a large
asset purchase
so just theoretically i want to buy some
real estate in switzerland okay
i want it to be above board i'm not
trying to do it on a clandestine basis
if today i wanted to send a million
dollars over to switzerland i would have
to disclose why
i'd have to get permission i'd have to
notify you know
the banks they would have to know by the
regulators that this transfer is
occurring
and i could purchase the land if i try
to do that with bitcoin the problem is
the
seller is not willing to take the
volatility
risk of bitcoin so if you're valuing you
know a chateau at 10 million
dollars u.s or 10 million swiss francs
and you want to pay in bitcoin you have
to somehow
guarantee that when the conversion hits
and it goes back to swiss francs or u.s
dollars that the seller gets
the accreter bottom out that tells me
the sellers do not have the
confidence to do large transactions yet
in bitcoin
now i'm sure that can change over time
but it is not
today the other issue with it is i wish
i agree with your premise that we could
get
international global currency that i
could avoid exchange fees in other words
when i want to go buy something in
british pounds
i have to pay the conversion fee from
the us dollar which i do all the time
because i have an etf in england
and i have one in in euro and i have one
in swiss franc so i have that major
headache i wish i could just do it with
bitcoin
i can't and so the reason is the
regulators in these countries don't
agree yet that bitcoin is the standard
so if all the regulators agreed that
bitcoin was the standard for the globe
you would be 100
correct but that is not the case right
now i totally agree with your premise
that the globe
needs a digital currency 100 percent
what i agree
if you told me the swiss and the euro
and the american
and the canadian australian governments
agreed to whatever that
is i would put up to 20 of my portfolio
in it
because then i could move across those
geographies easily without paying all
the fees
associated with converting from one
currency to another love that idea
now that was attempted as a payment
service with facebook as you recall
initiative that started early last year
that went nowhere
so far but that was a great idea because
they wanted approval from the government
but the fed didn't give them that the
sec didn't either not yet
but i think it's inevitable you're
correct but you have to bet if you're
betting on bitcoin if you're buying it
today at 18 000 whatever it is
that that is going to the de facto
currency and i don't think you have
enough assuredness
of that yet so this is really
interesting because
there's kind of um an evolution of
currency you described it earlier of
right now the volatility makes it really
hard to use as an actual currency right
but obviously as a store of value
uh somebody like yourself who's got five
percent of uh your portfolio in gold
do you look at it as wait this could be
digital gold and actually can do a
better job
preserving your wealth right last year
it's up 90 this year's up over 175
so far whereas gold has been up but it's
only up you know 20
or so this year do you ever think about
maybe you should take
half of your gold allocation and put it
into the digital gold version
so leave two and a half percent in gold
two and a half percent in bitcoin
you know i have thought about that but
you know
fortunately five percent of my portfolio
is a lot of money
and you know it's sort of if i'm going
to do this
am i willing to live with the volatility
that that brings into my portfolio
having days around down
10 12 even 30 on bitcoin it's extremely
volatile gold actually is not that
volatile
it's it's it's a you know something's
been around for 2000 years and it's a
very good edge against inflation still
is
but you may be right if i'm willing to
add let's say one percent of my
portfolio to bitcoin
i would want to know what the most
liquid way to do that was and i haven't
even researched it yet because
that's the other thing there's a lot of
fees associated with getting in and out
of bitcoin
that i don't understand why i'd have to
pay if it really is a currency i should
be able to be very liquid in it
and that's not easy to do and also
because i'm
you know an issuer of securities in the
sense i'm a shareholder
in uh something like uh start engine
which is now
doing crowdfunding and you know a huge
advocate for that
and i own a portion of of oh shares 50
of that manager i would want to make
sure that everything i do is approved by
the regulator i can't afford to go
offside in any way
and every time i talk off the record to
the regulators because i talk to them
all the time
for various reasons they're a little
squeamish on bitcoin they're not quite
there yet
when can you get this thing regulated so
that i can put
millions of dollars into it and know
that i'm not offside
and that in any way i'm not breaching
anything and that frankly it would be
stable if that was the case if tomorrow
morning we woke up and the sec said
you can create an etf with bitcoin and
we think bitcoin
is a legitimate you know payment system
and storage of wealth
not only would it go up but you'd have a
lot of people like me investing in it
because i'd say okay i'm going to give
it a 5
waiting so you know i don't really want
a significant portion of my portfolio
having that amount of volatility
i remember i started this conversation
saying i want to preserve
wealth that's what i try and do that's
what my what i'm all about
but you're right it's been a great asset
class
this year until it had its big sell-off
last week and it's big run up again
today that kind of volatility scares a
lot of people away
absolutely and i think what's really
interesting is like you really
highlighted an
important point which is the bitcoin etf
right because people in the bitcoin
community
what they would argue is um yeah there's
companies that have bought bitcoins you
can buy the companies and kind of get
indirect exposure
there's things like the grayscale
bitcoin trust which really is kind of
this
um you know again you get an etf like
product but it's not actually an etf
uh in international uh exchanges you can
get etps and things like that but there
hasn't been that etf
and i think many people who listen to
this that come from the bitcoin world
will actually be surprised
uh to understand that traditional
investors the etf
is this big kind of um breaking of the
dam or
or kind of approval point that will
allow a lot of capital to flow in that
just is sitting on the sidelines saying
hey this is interesting but
i'm not going to buy it until we have
that kind of a approval or check mark
right
well what i would like and the reason i
suggest an etf i'm very comfortable with
etfs and i live in that world
the majority of my money invested in
etfs and the ones i've created myself
ousa ogig oer ousm they've been very
good
capsules of preservation of wealth for
me because i helped design them myself
what i would like to have in a
cryptocurrency would give me the top
seven cryptocurrencies put them into an
etf
wrapper and let me invest in it with
liquidity so that i can
if i want to buy a million dollars worth
of it in the morning and sell a million
dollars in the afternoon i can do that
in an etf format
but to me i don't believe that you can
only have one
successful cryptocurrency there must be
the idea
that there's other and alternative ways
ethereum and others
that would also benefit from the overall
move to a cryptocurrency
payment system you know preservation of
wealth vehicle whatever it's going to be
and i would prefer to own them in a
probably market cap weighted basis
in an etf that to me would make a lot of
sense and frankly
i'm not the only person that says this
many others would but when you go to the
regulator like the winklevoss
twins have done and i think many others
have applied for these
applications i even looked at it once
never went anywhere with it because the
regulator basically said no
and so until the regulator says yes you
won't get that institutional
you know you identified something very
early on we talked about cannabis
the importance of the institutional
investor long term to support
a sector you want that institutional
investor supporting bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies
they're not there yet it's a slow creep
into it
but you can't deny the success of
bitcoin this year
but it's just this year what happens if
there's a correction next year
that's the issue the institutions have
absolutely uh before i let you go uh i
want to ask
one question which is when you think of
your portfolio today how do you
break that down whether it's on a
percentage basis or kind of just
buckets you obviously have a majority i
think of your portfolio invested in kind
of equity based
etfs and other sorts of vehicles what
else is in there or kind of on a
percentage basis how do you think about
your portfolio
construction yeah it's an interesting
question and every investor has a
different way of looking at it here are
the rules i live by that worked for me
i've even recently been teaching my son
this has gotten very interesting
investing too
i never have more than five percent in
any one
stock or asset so never more than five
percent in any one
concentrated elements that's why gold's
only ever five percent of my portfolio
i never have more than 20 in any one
sector
like energy or technology you know we
have 11 sectors in the s p
i have many private assets i think right
now i'm sitting
at about 30 percent in of my net worth
in private companies a
wide massive diversity of them and i
value them based on their ability to
generate
cash flow because i'm very fortunate i
get to see a lot of interesting deals
and i put money
to work in them and they're all kinds of
technology companies and
the etf company i talked about oh shares
for example and many many many many
others
and then for a long time and this has
been a big change for me
for you know 20 plus years i had a
massive portfolio of real estate
and i've recently taken down that that
portfolio from a 31
waiting so way over the 20 it had grown
so
large and real estate's relatively a
liquid you can't just flip a building
and i've reduced it down to eight
percent in the last nine months because
i'm seeing this
digitization of america i'm using less
office space
you know 78 foot aaa towers aren't going
to be worth as much as they used to be
because people don't want to get in
later with 60 people i know when cove is
over
15 of people that are working from home
are going to stay there
so i think there's going to be a
reduction in that element of real estate
that i used to own a lot of and i also
i realize all of these these stores that
i used to sell all my products in
we're never opening those marginal
stores and all those strip malls we're
never going to open those again we're
selling direct to customers so i sold
all those too
and so now i'm sitting on a mountain of
cash over 34
in fact we're just doing the numbers
last week uh for the year-end
i've never had so much cash in my life
and i've got to put it back to work so
i'm really really interested
in finding the next mind meds and these
big ideas
that that i can redeploy my capital into
so
you know america 2.0 is not going to be
the same
as as the old america was those old
stalwart assets like real estate are
gonna be worth as much
you know a movie theater chain or bed
bath and beyond close 200 stores
i bet you those get converted into
climate-controlled storage facilities
for
everybody that's shipping direct to
those suburbs but they won't be stores
anymore maybe they'll condos maybe their
cloud kitchens
but i'm glad i have a lot of dry powder
i'm ready to go
back and redeploy and i'm looking for
ideas and i want to back management
teams
i'm an investor i love entrepreneurs and
i just feel invigorated and
very optimistic that what's coming in
the next couple of years is going to be
really really interesting and i'm ready
i'm ready to invest take one percent put
in bitcoin you'll be very happy my
friend
i can't argue with you but i gave you a
lot of reasons that you got to think it
through a little bit
and i think some of those like if we had
a debate i mean i am not against bitcoin
i'm not against it but
you know when you're talking about
putting millions of dollars to work you
really want to understand
that you can think long term about it
and i have a feeling there'll be other
alternative ideas
maybe i should put some to work maybe
you've convinced me it's a major benefit
of our time together today maybe i put a
little bit more in just for the heck of
it i have a little bit
just so i can watch the price but um
you know it bothers me when i can't get
the regulator on board i really
there would be so much interest in
bitcoin are you ready for this
just i'm gonna blow your mind right now
two years ago
uh myself and uh my partners we raised
money from u.s public pensions
and bought bitcoin with it so u.s public
pensions are doing it fidelity they've
got a whole business doing it paypal
they got the regulators to approve it
the occ they came out they said that
banks you can custody of this
right i agree with you that this is i
know i'm aware of that but if you
actually look at the percentage of their
assets invested in bitcoin it is
so small that it doesn't even show up in
an other
category point zero zero zero zero but
believe me i know what institutions are
doing that's my whole job
watching institutional funds sovereign
pension plans just by one percent
just one percent yeah no it's true but
even the sovereign guys aren't there yet
i mean
but when bitcoin becomes a sovereign
pension plan asset i'll know about it
before you
i love it all right ask everyone one
last question i'll let you go aliens are
you a believer or a non-believer
i believe there is life uh outside of
the uh
the ecosphere of the of the earth
there's no question
um there's just so many i'm i'm a big
fan of of space and i track it it's
almost a hobby for me
i read a lot of the research i am a
believer that there are
uh organisms alive outside of our planet
and i think we're going to start
when we start scooping you know more
soil from mars and bringing it back
looking for micro you know all kinds of
micro life
we'll probably find some it won't be it
shouldn't be a surprise to people that
other conditions can exist
somewhere in the billions of star
systems that are out there so
yes i'm a believer in aliens i love it
kevin o'leary ladies and gentlemen
thank you so much i really enjoyed it
take care my friend